Wait, what?
Why is my mic so low?
Your mic is actually not low.
Do not make it loud.
No, I'm on my OBS.
I'm on OBS.
It's like low on my OBS.
It's like at the yellow.
It shouldn't be at the yellows.
That's the thing.
The yellow?
It was supposed to be at red, so they died?
Yeah, no, it's supposed to be at the red.
Okay.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Yeah, it should be like touching the red.
So it's like...
No?
Wait, actually, let me see.
Yeah, it's so low.
It's almost at the green.
I'd be always at the reds.
That's so weird.
The red is the bad one.
No, it's good.
It's good when you're the streamer.
It's...
Guys, we're just a little messy at the moment.
You're trying to kill all...
Wait, my sound...
You're trying to kill someone?
Wait, I'm going to tell Ditto to hop right in.
We need to hop in her channel.
Wait, we need to hop in her channel?
Because her channel is a live channel.
Oh, wait, are we not the live?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we're in general.
Wait, where's my disc green?
Where did it go?
I'm a mess right now, guys.
I'm...
I'm so tired.
You're a mess.
You're tired.
It's 2 a.m.
I'm tired.
She's tired, guys, but it's 2 a.m.
here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's start your idea.
How was I supposed to know it's in Japanese?
I'm tired.
Please, I can't read that.
I didn't know that means live.
Okay, I'm hopping in.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Wait, where's RP?
RPR's not hopping.
Okay, RPR.
Okay.
RPR's late.
Yeah, RPR's late.
He's late.
What is he doing?
Yeah, what are you doing?
You're late.
He's in game.
What's up, guys?
Yeah, and you're wasting our time.
He's in game.
Nobody's in here.
Are you down?
Hey, Dito.
Hey, what's up, Dito?
Why were you late?
We were waiting for you.
I just needed a moment of silence.
You need a moment of silence?
Why?
I just need to breathe in...
Breathe out...
Okay, so this game is all about coordination.
But like, we have...
We have... Each person is from a different region.
So...
I don't think that's gonna be the problem here.
Just gonna point that out real quick.
How is that not the problem?
I don't think ping is gonna be our biggest issue in this poll.
No, 100% ping is gonna be an issue.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
It's definitely gonna be an issue.
Because... What server?
What server is this?
NA.
It's NA.
America.
Yeah, yeah, so... I wanna say...
Um...
We're playing with no checkpoints, apparently.
Yeah, no, I said maybe we should do baby mode.
And then like, our PO was like, no, because chat's gonna bully us.
If we play baby mode.
So...
Was I wrong?
I'm saying...
I'm being a nasty girl.
I'm saying that like... I feel like we might need baby mode with the ping we have.
So...
Alright, so are you guys... Are you guys excited?
Have you guys played this yet?
I have.
Yeah.
No, this first time.
No, first time, first time.
Oh, okay.
So...
I am so happy that you guys are gonna be the first people I'm gonna play this game with.
I'm so excited to get this going.
I played with actually competent people, so I know what it was like to like...
You know, actually progress before I play with you guys.
So...
Okay, good.
Pause.
What do you mean by actually competent people?
Who are these competent people compared to me?
People who live in NA.
No, even the sound guy was like, did you turn yourself down?
You sound so quiet.
I know, sound guy.
There's something weird with my mic right now.
I don't know why.
I sound like more quiet than usual.
Oh, I should've... I don't know why.
It's so weird.
My shit is like fucked up for some reason.
I'm putting myself at a hundred.
Maybe that'll be better.
I'm not supposed to be in the reds.
You're not supposed to be in the reds.
Yes you are!
When you're streaming!
When you're the streamer, when you're the main character of your stream, you're supposed to be at the red and everybody else is supposed to be at the yellows.
Who made this rule?
Streamers made the rules!
I pushed myself up a little bit.
Maybe I should restart my... my... my GoXLR.
Give me a sec guys.
I'm gonna restart my GoXLR real quick.
We are so prepared for this callout.
What do you mean?
Look!
I'm making sure...
It's easy!
My god I can't hear you!
Where did you go?
You walked away from the mic?
This game is not that hard.
Okay.
Somebody's coping right now.
Wait okay.
Yeah no it's easy.
This game is easy by the way.
Okay so I'm gonna put myself at 100 because apparently...
I don't know what's going on with my GoXLR.
Okay are you guys ready?
Yes.
Are you guys... you guys are ready right?
Okay.
I'm playing.
I'm prepared yeah.
Let's get this pain train on.
Is this hard?
Alright.
What's about... what about this game?
Oh god okay I need to make sure the controls...
Oh my god is my mouse...
Yeah it's... it's bad.
It's bad.
Don't look at you guys.
Dito is fucking old.
Alright I'm... I'm homeless right now.
You guys are fucking old.
Alright give me a sec.
I'm saving my settings.
Don't worry guys I'm carry... I'll carry.
Don't worry.
Yeah yeah you're carry.
Are you guys ready?
Yeah yeah yeah.
You carry us.
Carry us.
Yeah carry us.
Yeah.
Also I hope...
I was... I was... I was dead here.
I'm following you guys.
Okay me too.
She's... she's useless.
We didn't even start man.
We're wasting time.
Let's go guys.
Look we have a timer.
Top left.
We're already 40 seconds in.
Oh it doesn't matter.
The timer doesn't matter.
No we're speed running.
We're speed running.
Let's go.
Come on.
We're gonna get speed run.
Why do we need a speed run?
We have to work together.
What is this?
Stop pulling.
It's like only up for multiplayer.
That's basically it.
Wait D2 you don't even know what the game is?
It's only up.
It's only up multiplayer.
Yeah.
Okay okay.
Okay it's easy because I clear only up.
Obviously we're not gonna beat the game.
So like what's the goal?
What's the... alright.
What are you doing?
I'm just my... I'm just my discord.
You pull it up.
How do I pull it up from there?
Jump.
Alright.
Just jump.
Alright I turn down my discord.
I turn down my discord guys.
Yeah okay guys.
Let me crack my knuckles.
Alright so we have to jump here.
Okay you guys ready?
Okay.
Jump.
I'm ready.
Okay you guys are not ready.
You guys are not ready.
You're killing us.
I said are you guys ready?
Alright jump.
Jump.
What are you guys doing?
What the fuck?
Together.
Jump.
Pause.
Okay.
Let's talk about strategy.
Let's talk about strategy right here.
You don't need to count.
You just jump.
Look at how big this platform is.
No no no no no no.
We're gonna do one, two, three jump every single time.
This is the platform.
It's so big.
We don't need it.
One, two, three jump.
Okay.
You are all stupid.
We're not gonna do this.
You jump on two.
Ditto.
Okay.
One, two, three jump.
Oh okay.
Ditto I said you jump on two.
No.
Alright ready.
One, two, three jump.
Why do we need jump one two three for this?
Oh my god.
Okay.
One, two, three jump.
Ditto you're always the one behind.
No.
I mean.
I mean, feeling!
Feeling!
I have like...
You have the splines out of the three of us!
It's a kindergarten, we didn't start.
I bet you when I look behind, Ditto's gonna be the one in the very back.
If you fall down and you pull me down with you, I will...
Ditto,
get over here!
I just wanted to know what...
Okay, we go right, we go right, we go right!
We go right, we go right!
Give me a good reason to go right.
Okay.
Jump!
One, two, three, jump!
Because it's literally faster!
If I touch this, do we die?
No, you don't die in this game.
You don't die in this game.
So why is the laser here?
It knocks you off.
I got this, I got this.
Follow me, follow me.
No, it's on the right!
You see that fucking Bowser shit?
The Super Mario shit!
It's the same shit if you go left or right!
What are you on about?
It's closer to go this way!
Which way?
What is this?
It's Super Mario!
It's Mario!
Okay, okay.
You know what?
You can IGL.
No, no, I don't want to IGL.
I need to turn down my Discord.
No, no, it's okay.
No, no, no, no.
I need to turn down my Discord anyway.
Alright, I'm ready.
As the oldest person here, you...
You have to IGL.
I'm 12.
No, 13.
Fuck!
Is this Dr. Disrespect?
Oh my god!
I don't want to talk to you anymore.
What are you doing?
No, no, no!
Pull me, pull me, pull me!
Okay.
What are you doing?
Wait, wait!
Second bounce we go, okay?
Second bounce we go to the other side.
This is the second bounce.
The second bounce.
Okay, here we go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
The second bounce right here.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Wow, great IGLing.
All I'm saying is I have yet to fail as an IGL.
Chat, I'm not banned.
I'm not banned.
I hope I get banned.
Oh my god, he admitted he was 12 years old.
He's not allowed on Twitch.
Report him!
I literally have my government information.
They have my government information.
Okay, right side, right side, right side.
Oh my god.
Right side, right side, right side.
Go, go, RPR, go!
You're pulling me back!
You cannot say I'm pulling you back.
You have to be specific.
Because it's not me.
You're so fucking...
I'm pulling both.
Look at who's at the furthest back.
And it's not me.
RPR, I fucking climbed!
Okay, now I don't remember.
Can I skip here?
I don't remember where to go.
I think it's also far.
No, no, no, you can't.
You can't.
You just keep jumping back up.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you?
Are you kidding me?
RPR, are you fucking kidding me?
What did I do?
I sat still.
You fucking did it!
Jesus Maria, bro.
How is this my fault?
You fell and it's all me!
I wasn't moving!
You pulled me!
And you fell!
What do you mean?
It was you!
How is it me?
Give me one good reason how that was me.
Because when you fell, I fell and then Vito fell.
You fell first!
You know what?
You're on Twitch.
Somebody clip RPR falling first.
I'm not on Twitch.
I'm banned.
Somebody clip him right now.
Clip him of him falling off first.
And then tag him and me.
And I'll retweet it.
Why did I sign up for this shit?
Also, clip him saying that he's... I don't know.
You try.
I'll try.
Okay.
Wait.
Vito, pull us up!
Pull us up!
E!
Hold E!
Press E!
Okay.
Go.
This is why we should have went beginner.
This is exactly why.
I don't know why we're not in beginner.
No, we're fine.
Look at this skip we just invented.
How are we fine?
We almost fell.
The amount of time it took us to pull each other back.
It's wasted our time.
We were falling because of you.
You need positive mental attitude.
Oh yeah.
I'm not positive here.
I'm not the positive one.
You know what?
We should let Ditto lead us.
We should let her lead us.
Yeah, you're doing great.
You're doing great.
You're doing great too.
Pull me!
Nah, did I sign up?
No.
What did I sign up for?
You said yes.
Focus up.
Walk the chain.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm fucking focused up.
But you guys are pulling me down.
Speedrun this.
There you go.
Speedrun.
Why are you guys so slow?
Speedrun right here.
Right side.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
My god.
You're right.
I know what I'm doing.
I don't know about you guys.
Well, you can't do anything that we don't do.
Because we're cheating together.
Some people play this game solo.
Which I don't understand why.
Because it's like...
What's the point?
It's basically only up.
I guess it's because you guys know only up is removed from Steam.
So they play this as if it's...
Yeah, it is.
It's removed from Steam.
So they play this as if it's only up.
I beat only up at a record world time.
Okay.
Somebody's fucking...
Yeah, you're lying.
Ditto, how long have you...
How long have you been awake, Ditto?
Um...
Maybe...
15 hours.
Oh my god.
Guys, she's been playing Palwo for 13 hours.
Calm down.
Stop pushing.
You can't push anybody.
There's no collateral.
There's literally no...
There's no collision.
There's no collision here.
What do you mean stop pushing me?
You can't push anybody.
Stop pushing.
You can push.
No, you can't.
There's no collision.
Stop pushing.
You're like... You literally are so far away from me.
How can we push you?
Alright, here we go.
Where are we going?
Right side.
It's always right.
How do you know right side?
It's right because I looked at the fucking bones.
What do you mean how do I know?
You look...
Use your eyes.
So if this leads to nothing, who do we blame?
Okay.
How many...
Gifted memberships?
How many gifted?
I don't got money.
You're not gonna get money out of me.
You're a fucking millionaire.
Like why are you...
I am not a millionaire.
Have you not seen my fucking re-debut?
Just because you spent your money doesn't mean you weren't a millionaire before you spent it.
Alright, here we go.
Oh here, jump set.
Second bounce.
Second... Oh my...
Where are we going?
Here we go.
Right here.
Okay, are you guys ready?
We have to go straight.
Alright, who's doing the countdown?
Now.
Go now.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Jump jump.
Climb it.
Climb it to the right.
Drop at the bottom one.
Now climb.
Jump over.
Go go go.
Okay, this is good.
This is easy man.
Easy.
How did that work?
It was simple dude.
Why are you panicking?
It wasn't even hard.
How did that fucking work?
I didn't...
Oh my god.
She wasn't even hard dude.
We made it.
Alright, ready?
Oh my god.
Now what is this?
What is this?
Oh, I don't know.
Who did that?
Who was it above me?
RPR.
What did you do RPR?
Oh, it's not me.
How is it my fault that you guys did that?
What do you mean?
You're the only one with a different skin than me.
I was the last one.
You guys are all...
Somebody clip it.
Somebody clip it on RPR's channel and then tag me and then I'll retweet it.
I'm gonna turn my stream off.
I don't even wanna be here.
I will retweet every mistake he's made.
Wait wait wait.
Just get up here.
Go.
Let's go.
Get up.
Okay, here we go.
What are you guys doing?
Oh my god.
What are you doing?
What are you pulling me?
What do you mean what are we...
You literally just walked off.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Ditto's just like, oh my god.
You're just waiting for us.
Yeah.
Why don't you wait for us RPR?
The only reason Ditto's hating on me is because you're here.
If you weren't here, she would hate on me.
No, she would obviously hate on you.
No dude.
You corrupted her.
We are not hating you.
We're just criticizing you.
That's different.
Okay.
First pause.
One step from hate.
Second jump.
Okay.
We go one line.
We go instantly.
Instantly run.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Climb to the right.
No.
Climb to this one and go.
Come on.
It's a skill issue if you can't do this.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That should not work.
Why does that work?
That's no question.
It is.
You're playing with a professional.
That should not work.
Alright.
We're okay.
Everything.
Okay.
Now I don't know what to do here.
Don't just spike.
Wait.
Wait for the spike.
Are you trolling me?
What are you doing?
You fucking climb.
Jump.
I am first.
Alright.
What happened to go?
I saved it.
What do you mean?
We all need to go at the same time.
We can go at the same time.
Wait.
Wait for me.
Right here.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Wait, wait, wait!
Ok, ok!
Go, go, go, go!
We're learning, but it's a learning process.
Why are you saying to be mad?
Wait, what's in here?
We don't care, we don't care.
Ok, ok.
I don't think there's anymore...
There is no spike here.
Yeah, we should be good.
There is no more spikes.
Okay, it's easy.
Okay, who is doing 3-2-1?
Who is doing it?
In one line.
In one line, okay.
Okay.
It has...
There is only one ride.
Next time it comes, we go.
Okay.
Okay, but who is counting down?
Now go.
Oh, okay.
Oh, we almost...
My god.
Oh, we are fine.
We are fine.
Let's not keep pool.
No, perfect.
Alright, ready?
3-2-1, go.
Alright, nice.
Why couldn't you do that earlier for the first one?
3-2-1, go.
Look at us.
We are a team.
3-2-1, go.
We are a team, guys.
We are a team.
Okay.
Okay, now we obviously have two choices.
We should do this one.
What is this?
Can we even...
Is this even a choice?
No, I don't think that's a choice.
It's not even a choice.
Yeah, we can't even do anything here.
Oh, hey, it's this one.
Let's get down here.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, you're gonna jump over this.
What are you guys doing?
Why did you just look at it?
Why were you guys looking at it?
3-2-1, go.
I was just admiring the view.
Oh, I'm too strong for my good.
Pull me, pull me, pull me.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
3-2-1, go.
Yay.
Okay, look at that, guys.
Oh, my God.
Perfect.
We should be a team, guys.
Where do we go?
Oh.
Up here.
And then...
And then what?
Up here.
Okay, and then what?
And then up here.
There's a ladder.
There's...
What?
There's a ladder.
Oh.
How are you supposed to see this?
We did all that and there's a ladder.
In my defense, I was cooking.
What were you cooking?
Clearly, it wasn't anything.
It's lazy.
We have to jump.
Okay, ready?
Okay.
Walk with me.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
Oh.
Jump.
Oh, no.
There's spikes too.
No.
Grab this ledge.
What's that?
There's spikes.
Here we go again.
Like, why didn't we play normal?
We gotta speedrun now.
We gotta speedrun.
Why didn't we play normal?
We are playing normal.
Why couldn't we do baby mode?
Doki.
You think that our chat would let us fucking play nothing but normal?
We just don't tell them.
You think they don't know this game?
They know more about this game than we do.
Every time we drop off, we turn off our stream.
And then...
We hide our screen every time we turn and we drop off.
And then respawn.
What?
For scientific purposes, what is your title?
My title...
What do you mean?
Is a science change gator.
With Doki and Appio.
Wait, what was the title?
What was your title?
Wait, I wanna know what your title was.
What was it?
Just go... Just read it.
Should I take a screenshot?
Chain together with Doki and Appio.
I don't know.
Wait, what are we supposed to look at?
It says chain together with lovely Doki and...
The handsome RPR.
Yeah, that's what it says.
Yeah, it says that.
Can you read this for me?
What are we supposed to look at?
What do you see?
Yeah, what do you see?
Nothing.
Don't worry guys.
I'll just show this.
What was it?
What?
What is it?
See, I told you.
It's not...
Are you gonna flame me?
Yeah, why are you flaming her?
She has...
Oh my god!
Look at what you're doing RPR!
RPR!
RPR, what are you doing?
Guys, guys.
How is this my fault?
I didn't even move!
I didn't even move.
Now you're throwing.
Why are you throwing?
You didn't move, so we fall, okay?
Yeah!
We're clearly trying to do something here.
We're trying to be gamers and you're like...
Ah, let's go then.
Let's go.
Go.
3, 2, 1, go.
Wait, are we jumping on one or are we jumping at go?
Go.
Why can't we jump on one?
It's easier.
Because it's 3, 2, 1, go.
It's obviously you jump on go because why would you...
I don't know.
I don't know because...
3, 2, 1, go.
Because like sometimes you guys are...
Yeah, see?
Just... we don't need to do 3, 2, 1.
It's the beginning.
Okay, you wish to say go every time?
Yeah.
By the time we hear go, the ping will... yeah, you would jump because of ping.
I bet you if you just say go, we'll be so coordinated.
Why am I eye-jelling?
Alright, watch this.
Go.
See?
Look.
Go.
You don't need to go for this.
I would hope.
Look at us go.
We're so good.
Alright.
Come on, Ditto.
Alright, second jump.
Second jump, we...
We can jump, okay?
Second jump, okay?
Alright.
Second jump, you're here.
Now we go.
Go.
Alright.
Second jump.
Okay.
Go.
See?
Go works.
One.
Two.
Go.
Good job, guys.
Good job.
Look at that.
Keep moving.
Okay.
Guys, I think we're gamers.
Yeah.
I think we're doing really well.
Wait, did any of us actually beat OnlyUp?
I said it was easy.
I did.
I beat OnlyUp.
Easy.
Don't...
Don't beat something like that.
You beat OnlyUp.
I beat OnlyUp.
Then why are you so...
I think I beat OnlyUp like under an hour.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, but then why is...
Why are you struggling?
I got less than an hour.
I beat it in 30 minutes.
That was my speedrun record.
Because...
Doki.
I am chained to you.
You understand?
That is why I suck right now.
But I had a speedrun record of 30 minutes.
No, you didn't.
Yes, I did.
Liar.
You're the liar here.
You're the liar.
You did not beat it in under less than an hour.
Yes, I did.
There's...
There's wads out there.
Where's the proof?
In the wads.
Like...
What wad?
Why would I lie?
Is he lying?
Yeah, he's lying.
You see what you did?
I don't know.
That's two to one.
Even my chat...
My chat...
My chat that's never on my side is saying he did.
There's a wad.
My chat was like, he's lying.
Okay, but your chat's wrong.
My...
I don't know.
My chat's wrong.
On the next one, we're running straight.
Go.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
See, look at that.
It's that easy.
RBR, it's not good to lie.
It's not good for your heart.
How...
How can you come so fast?
How?
Because I'm good.
Because I have legs.
I have...
Why?
Why are you so slow?
I don't know.
I just...
Come on, we're passing.
We're passing the bear.
Okay, to be fair, the ping is not as bad as I thought.
Okay.
I don't think ping matters in this game.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
Stop.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
We die together if we fuck up.
Okay, there you go.
See, look at that.
Okay.
It's that easy.
Move, move, move.
Speedrun only.
What even is the speedrun for this?
We will...
I wonder.
Chat, what's the speedrun?
I mean, we can literally look at...
My chat said it was under 45 minutes.
Okay, so this is like an 8-hour game then.
Go!
No, I'm talking only up.
Oh, only up.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, pull me.
Okay, perfect.
Okay.
Go.
Why are you singing in pink after me?
Go, go, Power Rangers!
Okay.
Up here.
Okay, let's wait for the next ship.
Okay.
I'm waiting.
If I could push, I would push you.
I was just thinking if I could punch in this game.
Holy shit.
Okay, we don't need callouts for this.
This is like your own adventure for that.
Okay.
Up here.
Ready?
Yeah.
Go.
How come whenever you say go, you wait like two seconds and then you jump?
Yeah, because I have to.
All right, all right.
Let's not get fucked here.
I don't know what happened last time.
Okay.
What was that?
So it's a laser and then it spikes.
Okay, it's because we touched the laser.
If we touch the laser, we drop off.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
If we touch the laser.
No, we don't touch the laser.
We don't touch the laser.
We will be okay.
So jump over the laser and then jump over the laser again.
Okay?
Okay.
Ready?
Why?
Okay.
Right here.
Jump.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh my God.
You're crazy.
Not even close.
What's that?
Not...
Guys, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I need to grab the cough drop.
Okay, I'm ready.
This way.
Okay.
Right side?
Hold now.
Right side.
It has a trampoline.
Ready?
On.
Go.
Okay.
Second jump.
All right.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Second jump.
Two.
Fox, fox.
What's this?
Jump and jump key to...
How do we...
How do we do it?
Jump and hold jump key.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye.
Guys, guys, guys.
I'm leaving.
Guys, I'm leaving.
Don't let go.
Guys, I'm leaving you guys.
You're helping us get up there.
What the fuck?
Look at them getting carried by the giga chat that I am.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Straight carry.
This way.
We're just waiting.
Where are we going?
Why did you...
Okay.
I was like, why did you let go?
What was this?
It was a car.
Sit back.
Let me drive.
Okay.
It was a car.
Let me drive, guys.
Okay.
Oh, red car.
Yay.
We don't have to do anything, Ziddo.
We don't have to...
It's RPR's fault.
Yeah, it's RPR's fault.
We die.
RPR.
What are you doing?
Do you even have a driver's license?
Of course I do.
Who do you think you are?
Why?
Okay.
Why are you like getting hit by the thing?
It's literally like so big.
I'm not hit by the thing.
I'm not hit by anything.
Do you see us passing this stage with ease?
You're like reading your chat while driving.
You should never text and drive.
That's against the rules.
You need to close your chat right now.
Do you see what you're doing?
Do you want to fly off the map?
Because I can make that happen right now.
Yeah, but you're just prolonging your madness.
You see this?
I got us here in three seconds.
Look at me.
Wait, wait.
My character is shush.
Wait.
Yeah.
What happened?
I didn't know.
Wait, guys.
What was this?
I don't like this.
Oh, we have to jump to the...
When it rotates, we have to jump.
Yeah.
Follow the rotation.
It's like Fortnite.
I played this in Fortnite.
I did this in Twitch Rivals.
Fortnite.
Fortnite Battle Pass.
Okay.
I can do it.
Oh my God.
You became a...
Are you a woman or a...
No, you're still...
Wait, you became younger.
Or not?
I don't know.
You're the only prehistoric dinosaur in here, Doki.
Oh my God.
Hey, I have knowledge.
Okay?
The older you get, the more knowledgeable you are.
Maybe I died once and I was born.
Reincarnated.
You got reincarnated.
Are you guys ready?
Three.
Two.
One, go...
Okay.
Up.
Keep jumping.
Keep falling.
Okay.
Keep jumping on your own table.
Right side.
Pull up here.
Are you pulling me.
Side.
What the hell.
What the hell, what the hell?
Are you pulling me.
Back, back, back, back.
I'm not pulling you anywhere!
Stop coming!
Go forward!
I'm coming!
Jesus Christ!
Okay, I got this.
I got this.
Everything is okay!
I got it too.
There we go.
I got it too, guys.
I figured it out as well.
Go left.
Jump up here.
I'm here!
I can jump!
Okay.
Go right.
Jump up here.
See?
It's not so bad.
Go left.
It's terrible.
Okay.
Jump up.
Now wait.
No.
Wait.
Sit on this ramp.
Where are you going?
Sit on this ramp right here.
What the hell are you doing?
I got it!
What is she doing?
Okay.
Go!
What do you mean, what am I doing?
I'm just having a great time with my friends.
Go.
Yay.
See?
It's not so bad.
I feel like we're doing really well compared to other people.
Go.
I think it's just because we're gamers.
Are you guys ignoring me?
Go.
Yes.
I just wanted conversation.
This game should not just be go.
Sorry.
We need entertainment.
Go.
And she falls.
And she has to do conversation.
Go.
Our chat chat just here.
We need other stuff.
Do you want to win or do you want to lose?
Okay.
I'm already winning.
Go.
Second jump.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This way.
Here we go.
Now here comes the pain train.
Analyze.
We jump left.
Then we jump right.
And then we jump left.
We go go go.
Left right left.
Go.
We just fucking do this.
Yay.
You did it.
What is this button?
Oh it's timed.
I think we should do it.
Wait wait wait.
No no it's timed.
It has to be timed because of the music.
I think it's timed.
Or not.
It's not?
It's not.
There's no time.
We're gonna wait longer.
But what if it's not?
Oh okay.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Okay.
Ready?
Go.
Go go go.
Faster faster faster.
Jumping only.
I am jumping.
What are you guys doing?
Stop climbing.
Just jumping.
What are you guys... I'm literally ahead of you.
Go faster.
Stop.
I'm literally ahead of you.
Stop climbing.
Good jump.
I'm really ahead of you.
Stop climbing.
Not even close.
It's not even close.
It's okay.
It's not close.
Yeah.
Go.
I think it's weird.
This game is not even hard.
How are people struggling with this shit?
Okay chat.
Hi guys.
Up here.
Okay okay.
What did you say?
This game isn't even hard.
Guys how long...
Is this thing... Is it gonna come back?
Well I hope so.
I hope so.
Oh there it is.
It just came back.
Yeah.
Okay ready?
Yeah we're ready.
How long is this game?
Guys we need to know.
Like an average completion rate.
How long is this game?
According to my calculations, 45 minutes.
We're not speeding.
Maybe we can do a speedrun.
Someone said 5 hours.
Someone was just like yes.
We've done 1 out of 10.
This is 1 out of 10th of the progress.
We have to swim?
How do we swim?
Control control control.
Yeah yeah yeah control.
Please I need a breathe.
Please please I will drown.
Wait can you drown?
I don't know.
I'm gonna try.
Okay ditto go drown.
It's 3600 meters and we did 500.
I don't think we can though.
We did 500 meters and 3600 meters.
Oh it's 3600 meters?
Like 3600?
Wait then we're 1 fifth.
5, 10, 15, 20.
Can you do math?
This isn't 1 seventh.
25, 30.
Oh what?
Haha.
Hahaha.
We're 1 seventh.
We're 1 fifth guys.
Oh yeah.
It's closer now.
500 meters.
Okay.
Alright.
Where is this?
We press buttons?
Boom.
Okay.
We have to press all the buttons.
There's a timer on them.
Wait right side.
Right side is closer.
Go to the right.
Okay.
Go here.
You don't have to jump there.
We can walk there.
No we can't.
What are you doing?
How do we walk?
Okay.
This way.
Listen to ditto.
Ditto knows what to do.
RPR.
Come here.
Alright.
And then what?
Up top.
We got bolted.
Pull me.
Up here.
Ready?
Up top.
Yeah.
And then we go to...
Right here.
See?
It's not that bad.
Oh it's Mario time.
It's Mario time.
Okay.
Be careful.
There's spikes.
I'm dead.
No.
We're pulling.
Go up.
Come on.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is bad.
This is really bad.
You know.
Can you like let go.
And then float away?
Haha.
Okay Okay.
Stop.
Get closer.
Why are you so far away.
Go.
Because we don't need to be that close.
What do you mean?
Yes we do.
Maximum time.
Okay.
No.
This is not a video.
Oh no, okay, okay.
I'm worried.
I'm worried about this.
He might need a 3-2-1.
How did you do it?
Going to thrown up?
We can save this!
WHY?
Why?
We're fine.
We're not even that far down.
Oh my god.
To be fair, that was very laggy.
That was not laggy.
I saved it twice and it kept teleporting me back in the air.
Somebody clip this.
Somebody clip RPR fucking up again.
I did not fuck that up.
That was you guys.
How was I on the other side?
You see what Ditto just did?
I was on the other side.
Oh fuck this again.
We don't need to coordinate.
We just need to use our eyes.
We don't need to coordinate this.
As long as our eyes work, we're fine.
Alright, ready?
Get closer.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
This side.
Okay, just wait.
Just use your eyes.
We don't need to coordinate this.
It's a thief.
Why?
Okay, wait.
Come back.
There's a car.
We can literally run.
The car is more dangerous.
No, it's not.
I'm a good driver.
Why didn't you use your eyes?
You did not need coordination for that.
You just needed to use your eyes.
No!
I'm getting off the car.
Get off the car.
I don't want to be in a car anymore.
I don't want to be in a car.
It looks easier.
Why are you not getting off the car?
Get off the car!
This is too close.
Oh my god...
Okay.
I swear to fucking god, I swear to god...
I know people ride bikes in Europe.
But that was terrible.
Okay.
You would do better.
We don't need the car.
We can literally use our legs.
It doesn't matter.
No, it's not.
What do you mean it's not?
Do you see how long the trail is?
Oh my God.
It doesn't matter.
The more time...
Focus.
Use your eyes.
Pull me.
Use your eyes, please.
Don't push me.
Pull me.
Use your eyes, please.
Okay, okay.
Okay, this one is easy.
This one is the easiest one.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the easier one.
Pull me.
This way.
Okay.
We don't have the word.
This is the easier one.
Go right.
Go left.
I'm going left.
Okay, I'm jumping.
I'm jumping.
Now go on the platform.
And wait.
Hey.
Why are you guys still waiting?
What do you mean?
I made it.
I cut some time.
Go.
I can jump backward.
I've fallen.
Oh my God.
I'm here.
I swear to God.
Do not fall.
Just keep going.
I swear to God.
I'm falling.
Why do you want me to do this?
Pull her up.
Press space.
I press space.
Okay.
No.
All right.
Ready?
Go.
Okay.
See?
Everything is fine.
Go.
There you go.
Now we don't need to go here.
I don't need to use go.
Because it's so...
See?
Everything is fine.
Go.
Look at that.
We're a team.
We're so coordinated.
Go.
Okay.
Second jump, guys.
Second jump.
All right.
And then...
Two.
Go.
Okay.
This one.
Now we just go forward.
Okay.
Go.
The next one.
Don't fall.
Okay.
Go.
The next one is the left one.
It's the left one right here.
Dita, Dita, where are you pulling me?
Don't get... You gotta save it.
You gotta save it.
I'm trying.
Okay.
Try to save it.
We'll save it.
What do you mean?
Oh my God.
That was not on me.
I was literally there.
I was there.
You two dragged me back down to hell.
Yeah.
Yup.
Guys, we can't reset because somebody was like, no, we don't need baby mode.
You think...
Yeah.
You think our chat would let us play baby mode?
You really think they would sign up for baby mode?
Yeah.
My drag rules would let me play baby mode.
No, they wouldn't.
Read your own chat.
You don't know them.
Go!
All right.
Use eyes.
We don't need coordination here.
Just use your eyes.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Our Pierre is not using his eyes.
Why am I climbing backwards?
He's not using his eyes.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump.
And then...
See?
All of... This is easy.
This one's so easy.
Faster, donkey.
Faster.
What do you mean?
I'm really faster than both of you combined.
Faster.
Look, I took that first.
I took that jump first.
Faster.
Pull me up.
Somebody's being a fucking...
Faster.
All right.
See?
We made it.
Faster.
I don't think we need coordination for... Okay.
We need coordination for this.
I don't think we... I'm dead.
I don't think we need to... Yeah.
I don't think we need to...
I don't think we need to jump that other box.
We can literally skip that one.
See?
Look.
We are reading each other's minds.
We're reading our minds right now.
Okay.
You guys need to be a little bit faster there.
All right.
Second jump.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Jump on the left one.
Okay.
Jump on this one.
I don't think we should have, but okay.
Jump on next one.
Jump on this one.
Okay.
Not bad.
I press button, we go.
Jump, not come, okay?
Guys, hurry up!
I can't get up because you guys keep fucking dragging me behind.
What are you talking about?
I'm ahead of you.
I'm literally ahead of you.
I'm literally ahead of you right now.
There you go.
Okay, okay.
See?
We're doing it.
Go.
Okay.
We did it.
Go!
Okay!
Oh my god.
There we go.
Everything's okay.
Unbelievable.
She's like, why are you guys pulling me back?
No one was doing anything!
Bitchy, no one was doing anything!
I mean, somebody was clearly pulling me back on my stream.
Swim?
Uh huh.
How did you guys do it?
Control.
Oh, control.
I did it.
Okay.
No swim?
You did it.
Okay.
Forward?
It was somebody's ping, but it wasn't my ping because I have the home advantage.
So you should be carrying.
So why am I carrying?
I was carrying, but somebody is a fucking cement blocker.
In my backpack.
Maybe it's me.
Why do you keep falling?
I have the true 100 LPC.
Wait, how do you know?
We can't see our ping here.
How do you know?
Maybe the servers are better.
Oh, we don't have to do this again.
Thank god.
Yeah, thank god.
Maybe there's better servers and chain together.
You don't know that.
Focus, focus.
Okay.
Not yet, not yet.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I told you guys.
Okay.
We are going to die.
Wait for it.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay, we're okay.
Just jump.
Walking.
I'm walking.
Stopping.
Okay, time it.
Now.
Ducky's.
Walking.
We can do this one by one.
We don't need a...
Stopping.
One by one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Walking.
See, I told you.
One by one.
Slow and steady.
Okay, wait now.
Wait now.
How the fuck?
Looking.
Analyzing.
Okay.
What?
We go this one, then the next one.
Oh, and then we jump on that one.
You see that one on the right side?
The next one?
Yeah.
Right side?
On the right side?
Okay, okay.
Go on this one.
Okay.
Then we just walk.
We should jump.
Go.
Now wait for next one.
Which is next one?
Jump, jump, jump.
It's pummel party.
Okay.
This one?
Now this one.
This one.
Okay.
And then we... That one.
That one.
To the right.
Yes.
Island.
Okay.
Yeah.
Safe.
Okay.
And then we walk up the log.
Don't fall off, guys.
Don't fall off.
Guys, don't falling.
Don't falling.
Go.
I falling.
Don't falling.
Go.
This is so anxious.
Okay.
Ready?
Go.
Oh my god.
There's all of us there.
We trained.
We're so good.
Okay.
This is easy.
Go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go.
Oh my god.
We all have to clap.
Go.
Double jump.
Why do it?
Okay.
Go.
Pull me.
Okay.
Go.
Alright.
I'm not go.
Go.
It's fine.
This one is so close.
We can't pull each other away.
Go.
Okay.
And then we made it.
One minute breathe.
One out of seven.
Okay.
Wait.
How do we... We have to walk up the sword?
Is it the sword?
Yes.
But sword is moving.
No?
No.
It's not moving.
It's... Yeah.
My brain moving.
Alright.
To the right?
Right.
Yeah.
Go.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Left.
Go.
Alright.
And then we walk up.
This is easy.
It's not... Yeah.
No talking, only moving.
Yeah, only moving.
No yapping, only move.
Okay, analyzing.
Okay, we walk.
Don't walk too fast or you'll fall off.
Careful walking.
What did I just say?
I'm walking.
I feel like we've devolved into cavemen.
Careful walking.
Go, jump, back.
I'm walking.
We're all walking.
We're all careful walking right now.
Move.
Yeah?
Where are we going?
Careful walking.
I don't need careful walking.
The aqua man.
Swimming, ice swimming, ice swimming.
Okay, but like how do we...
Can we drown?
No, no dying.
We go right side.
Okay.
Right side?
The right side.
Wait, what's the...
Then we go right side up.
Then we go back.
Wait, yeah, yeah, up top, up top.
Wait, how did you guys go up?
Space bar?
No, this is dead end, dead end.
Why are you so bad at with mazes?
What is this?
It's like ice seed for the first time.
What are you working on?
It's nearly 50-50.
How could you choose that?
What's the wrong 50?
Ditto, what are you doing?
Ditto, press space.
I'm doing.
I pressed space, but oh, you guys are too far.
I can't move.
All right, swim up, swim up.
Ditto, go up, go up.
Ditto, go up.
Come on, go up.
Ditto.
Ditto, what are you doing?
All right, down.
And then we go up here.
I pressed space, but I was...
Lying.
Donkey lying.
Okay.
And then, okay, 50-50.
Which way?
I take left.
Okay.
And then we go this.
That was a dead end.
I knew it.
Every time you led, it gave us a dead end.
I led us to the right area.
Blah, blah, blah.
My name is Donkey Bird.
Guys, guys, guys, your chains.
Your chains.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, see, there you go.
There you go.
Okay, fine.
I find it.
We did it.
No, I'm on top first.
I find...
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
No, what did you do?
What did you do?
What do you mean, what did you do?
No, it's not!
Doki, you swam into the fucking whirlpool.
No, I did not.
It was not me.
What did you do?
Clip that shit right now.
What the fuck did you do?
Wait, we go in here?
Oh no, the top.
It's the cars again.
It's the cars.
We have to do the car again.
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
R.P.R.
What did you do?
She fucked up.
Was it R.P.R.'s fault?
It is not R.P.R.'s fault.
It was R.P.R.'s fault.
R.P.R.
We saw it.
It was her, not gonna lie.
You're like, I'm Doki Berry.
And then you dragged us down.
You pushed Doki.
Yeah, you pushed me.
Why did you push me?
We worked so hard to do the maze.
It's clipped.
It's clipped and it's shipped.
The whole world is gonna see it.
It's not that far.
You said you're Doki.
No, it's pretty far.
I'm not Doki, what the fuck?
It's pretty far, Ditto.
We did a lot of stuff to get here.
No, it's not.
It's almost there.
It's pretty far.
We have to do the...
The thing where like...
The running up the thing.
Running.
One by one.
Stopping.
Okay.
Yes!
It's pink!
Okay.
One by...
This is why we do one by one.
Okay.
Please.
Ditto, please.
It's pink!
Going on this.
Okay.
It's not my fault.
You're right.
Now this next one.
Jump.
Okay.
Jump over the laser.
Jump on this.
Okay.
Next one we jump on.
Yeah.
I wouldn't scream.
This one.
Jump.
Okay.
Casually.
Up here, please.
Okay.
Ready?
Go.
Raises up 10 octaves.
Okay.
Now everyone stop here.
Look to your left.
This is where Doki fell through.
This hole you see above.
Okay.
Where?
Where's the hole?
What do you mean?
Jump.
Okay.
Come on guys.
Jump.
We can do this faster.
We're not even.
Okay.
We gotta be careful now.
Jump.
Pia stop saying jump.
That is my fault that you pressed paste.
Right side.
Okay.
This one we don't need coordination.
We can just walk.
Jump.
Nice.
All right.
Okay.
Walking.
Casual walking.
I'm walking.
This is hard.
It's like Mario Party.
The Yoshi thing.
The Yoshi crayon.
Never played Mario Party in my life.
Look at me.
I'm a fucking gamer.
Look at me go.
I know.
Stop it.
I'm swimming.
Left side.
I stuck.
This way.
Through the hole.
Left.
Up.
And then... was it right side?
Right.
Yeah.
Guys.
I'm still...
Give me a sec.
I'm stuck in a hole.
Don't make me go in the hole.
I will go in the hole.
Wait.
So we go through here and then we go...
We hold right...
Look.
Looking.
Swim into the wall.
Okay.
Swim with me.
We go here.
We're going here.
We go up here.
And then we're safe.
We're safe.
Let's go left.
Oh, f**k.
Careful.
Can we make this?
Okay.
Yeah.
Coordination.
Okay.
Three.
Two.
One.
Go.
Why did you guys not move?
Because it is Discord delay.
What do you want from us?
Oh my God.
Why did you jump?
None of us jumped.
None of us said jump.
I'm fine.
I'm safe.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Are you still safe?
All right.
Okay.
Nice.
What now?
What do we do here?
Wait.
What?
I think... I don't knowing.
Let's go slow.
How do we...
Can you crouch?
Yeah.
We can't.
How do we do this?
Wait.
Oh.
One of us has to fall and grip the other side.
I think...
Okay.
But you guys stay still.
I'm going to fall.
I will drop.
No.
Get closer.
Get...
No.
We can't.
We have to swing someone.
Come close to me.
What if we just climb over?
I don't think we can.
Okay.
I'll swing.
You guys stay close.
No.
You have to be on the pipe.
You have to be on the pipe right here.
Okay.
Ice...
You both need to stand here where I'm standing.
But what if we die?
Okay.
Then we're dead.
Ice wind.
Why did you fall?
Please explain.
Docky pull.
No.
I can't fall.
Wait.
We can save this.
No.
Oh.
Why you just stood there?
Why did you guys fall?
Wait.
That was not me.
I stayed on the locked-in.
Why did you fall?
No.
I was...
I was pull.
Right up here on the...
There is no way...
There is no way we actually have to do swing strut.
Right?
How can we swing?
Well, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know how to swing!
I don't know!
Can we swing?
Alright, are you guys ready?
Uh-huh.
Okay, you guys were not ready.
You guys were not ready.
Doki, what are you doing?
Doki, Doki, Doki!
You guys were not ready!
I don't understand!
I can't anymore.
She's just strolling right now.
No, she's strolling.
We can't make a swing.
Jump.
How is it me?
You guys want to pull me back though?
You're the one swinging off the fucking air!
No!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I did my job.
We can't even...
We can't even figure it out.
What do you mean distribute weight?
We don't know how to do that shit.
It's stupid.
I'm not throwing!
RPR is just a bad IGL.
I'm not even IGL-ing.
RPR, oh no, Chido, what are you...
Guys, guys, guys, please.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
I'm not throwing!
I'm throwing!
Chido's not trolling.
It was a ping.
Sometimes I feel like it's not ping.
I don't know.
It's a ping.
Okay, Dan, why don't we create a server in Asia?
Why don't...
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
Great ping.
What are you doing?
I'm just trying to...
Okay, let's not lose here, guys.
Let's not...
Go.
I went too far!
Pull me!
We're trying!
Oh my god.
Jump.
We can literally go all the way.
I'm too strong.
Okay, we don't need to coordinate for this.
I feel like we know what to...
Can you like not jinx us every time?
We made it.
I told you we didn't need it.
Second jump.
On two.
Wait.
Waiting.
We're waiting.
This one, this one, this one.
Okay.
And then hop.
Next, next, next.
And then hop, hop, hop, hop, hop.
Hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop.
Okay, ready?
Going, going, going.
Why are we still climbing?
Stop pulling me back.
I know climbing.
You climbing.
No one's pulling you back, dumbass.
You're pulling me back!
It literally shows on my screen that you're pulling me back.
No one's pulling you back.
You guys are dead weight.
Oh my god.
I go without you guys.
Nice, we did it.
Nice.
We made it.
This is it.
I wanna go right side.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
I wanna go and...
bring around the room.
We get over here.
What are you doing?
Why are you not working as a team?
I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna run off.
Where's the thing?
You sent it the way.
No, I didn't.
It's right here.
See, we're almost there.
We're almost...
Alright, jump off.
I will fall right now.
Up here.
Pull me.
Pull, yeah, I pull you.
Wait, how is he gonna make it?
Actually.
I don't know.
Pull me.
Up here.
Okay, we made it.
This way.
This way, this way.
This way, this way, this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna be able to get out of here.
I don't think we're gonna beat this, guys.
I don't think we're gonna beat it, guys.
Well, we got out of here.
I think the swing time is pretty high.
Guys, the speed run for this is 2 hours and 30 minutes, guys.
We're halfway there!
That's the speed run.
We're halfway there.
One hour and 4 minutes.
How do we swing?
Swing.
Maybe Doki go first.
They were strong in my life, to be honest.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll...
Doki?
Hey, guys.
Can somebody pull me?
Only Akiya can pull you.
No, you can pull other people.
No, I can only pull you.
I can pull Doki.
Yeah, we should all be able to pull because we're open.
This is an open chain.
This is the easier chain because we're an open chain.
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, RPR.
Slow.
Slow guy.
Alright, down we go.
I'm ready.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I feel like I aged 20 years playing this game.
I'm not gonna lie.
I feel like this game has taken some of my lifespan.
One at a time.
Now you... okay.
Okay.
Let Dino go first.
No!
I'm not taking Dino!
Go first!
No, I go first.
Okay, Dino, your turn.
No, no, Dito, no, no!
Let her go first!
Just let her go first!
Please!
Dito.
Dito, Dito, you're trolling!
Dito, you're trolling!
Okay, you're both on the other side.
Wait!
Oh my god.
We did it!
We fucking...
We fucking did it.
I don't know how, but we did it.
Oh my god.
This one, this one, this one.
Okay, here.
Okay, jump, laser.
Laser jump, laser jump, laser jump.
Boing.
This one, this one, this one, this one.
Okay.
And then the sound.
Alright.
Okay.
It works, guys.
How did you do that thing?
It's okay in the end.
It just works.
Go in!
Okay.
Okay, three.
Jumping.
Okay.
Okay, okay, go, go, go.
Jumping.
Alright.
This guy is screaming.
Okay.
It's because it's hell.
We're in hell.
Of course we're going to be screaming.
Okay.
No, someone else is screaming.
Yeah, I know, but like, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Hell is just not us three.
There's other people in hell, like our chat.
Are we like climbing to heaven?
Yeah, we're trying to climb out of hell.
We're not gonna go to heaven.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
We're not gonna go to heaven.
Why can't we go to heaven?
We don't deserve heaven.
We just go to the hell that's like a higher level.
Just a higher level of hell.
Yeah.
Oh, it's like the nine circles of hell.
We don't deserve heaven.
What do you mean?
I'm a good person.
No, only you.
What do you mean?
Only you.
The only reason why we're in hell is because of you.
You don't deserve heaven.
Yeah, you don't deserve heaven.
And because we're chained to you, we're forced to not be at heaven.
Why are we chained?
Pull me up!
I couldn't.
I couldn't pull anybody.
Wait, land on the island!
Land on the island!
Why did you fail?
Why did you fall?
See, this is why we're in hell!
This is exactly why we're in hell!
You keep falling!
It's because I'm chained to you guys and Ditto keeps falling!
I didn't fall first!
You fell first and then pulled me.
Yeah, you fell first and then you pulled Ditto down.
And then I couldn't do anything because we were on the log.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip, clip.
I did not fall first.
It was Ditto.
Ditto fell first.
I didn't fall.
I didn't do anything.
She is trolling.
No, you fell first.
You fell first and then you pulled me.
You fell first.
I saw it.
How could you fall?
That is not true.
You guys are lying.
No, we're not lying.
You're just in denial.
You're really in denial.
I fell second.
You're in denial.
Your Piri is wrong.
You fell first.
You fell first, RPR.
I saw you.
You didn't see it, Donkey.
No, you have to watch my POV.
RPR.
You have to watch my POV too.
You totally fell first.
I saw it.
I'm gonna.
What are you going to do?
You're chained to us.
You can't do anything.
Okay, I don't want to move.
You guys pull me.
Okay, we won't move either.
Okay, how do we move here?
Okay.
I'm stronger than both of you.
What happened?
Why did you say we weren't gonna move?
We better move or we die.
Would you like to die or would you like to move?
If we die, we won't have to play this game anymore.
This was your idea, by the way.
I thought it'd be fun.
But I didn't realize how bad you'll be at the game, RPR.
You're worse than me.
And...
Oh my god.
You're the worst one here.
Am I the worst one here?
We have Ditto.
Oh, this one again.
He's still in pink.
No, RPR.
Save it, save it, save it, save it.
RPR.
That was pain.
Land it, land it, land it, land it.
Oh, you're so smart.
Someone save me from this hell.
Someone save me.
We have to jump from here.
3, 2, 1, jump.
You jumped too.
I'm gonna throw up.
What happened?
Okay, I go first.
I go first.
Okay.
This is on you guys.
I volunteer to go first.
I even volunteer.
These big ones can do anything to us.
Yeah?
What happened?
Sorry, I'm just too good at the game.
I'm just too good at the game that nothing happened.
It's really hard to throw.
You know?
It's so hard to throw when I'm just that naturally gifted at that chain together.
You're naturally gifted at ruining your teammates mental health.
Wow.
Why?
Okay.
Can we cut this chain off?
I called your fucking bluff.
I wish there was a...
Yeah?
You're so dumb.
Get in the fucking car.
You have to get on it first.
Follow you.
I just follow you.
Yeah, we're just following you.
Yeah.
You jump down so I jump down.
Yeah, you're the leader.
Oh my god.
I can't even fall.
I can't fall.
I'm too good at driving.
I literally can't fall.
Oh.
RPR stop reading your chat while you're driving.
You're not supposed to text and drive.
RPR.
You're setting a bad example to everybody.
Oh.
Don't drink and drive kids.
Oh no.
Alright, let's do this again.
Let's do this again.
Yeah, none of us are gonna troll, right?
Hey.
Whoa.
I feel fresh.
I wish there was one chain you could cut off.
And I would cut off a chain and let it come back to hold me.
Okay, ready?
Yes.
I'm ready.
You're special.
Oh my god, you're getting us killed.
I didn't get us killed.
This is the one that I'm better at.
Than all of you.
Yeah, cause the ping.
Yeah, yeah, ping, ping.
Yeah, yeah.
It's always the ping.
Can't blame everything on the ping.
Okay, let's play on my server then.
Oh yeah, sure.
Let's play on your server.
Let's do it.
Yeah?
She's special.
I said let's go.
If we go on my server, we lose all of this progress, right?
Well, that's fine.
We could do it all again on your server.
You stop bluffing.
I'm not gonna take your bluff.
Stop bluffing.
You know you won't.
I will totally go on your server.
I'm not bluffing.
I'll do all of this again.
Just to prove a point.
Let's all take four together then.
I can leave and this lobby will close.
Jump.
I'm not doing this.
Listen, if you leave, I'm not doing this all over again.
I'm not doing this all over again.
What happened?
I would do better, but you would do worse.
And you're already really bad.
Wow, okay, let's prove a point.
Let's prove a point.
We'll play on your server.
You're not gonna sacrifice all this progress to prove a point.
I will.
I'm gonna go to bed.
It's 3.30 AM.
I'm giving you 30 more minutes.
I'm giving you 30 more minutes for this game.
And I'm going to bed.
You're giving me 30 minutes?
Ditto's been streaming for 16 hours.
Whose fault is that?
Your fault.
How is it my fault that you're streaming for 16 hours?
Jump on this one.
What are you doing?
Just jump on it.
Stop complaining and jump.
I'm carrying again.
Oh my god.
I'm carrying.
Okay, ready?
Go.
Guys, I need you guys to stop being so behind.
Because you're forcing me to climb.
I'm literally in front of you.
You're pulling me back.
You are special.
We made it.
RPR, you're so slow.
Dinah and I were in the front.
I'm going to jump.
You did not make it to the box.
Because I got pulled.
Who pulled you?
None of us.
Okay.
I got two Dalash's chained to me.
Are you including yourself?
No, look.
Red and orange.
I'm colorblind.
What's that?
Green, green, green.
What does green look like?
I'm colorblind.
Not red.
Oh, wait.
So you're red.
What kind of colorblind are you?
It's like you're really red.
I'm a rare kind of colorblind.
I don't remember the name.
Apparently one out of a million kids get it.
I'm not at the bottom yet.
I need to swim.
You're so special.
You're one in a million special.
Yeah, I'm one in a million.
Look, see?
We made it back, guys.
We did it.
This does not feel like an hour.
I feel like I've been playing this game for like four hours with you two.
I...
We've been playing for four hours.
I feel like this has been four hours.
How is this only an hour?
I don't understand how this is only an hour.
Toki, for someone who's played before, you're not very good at this game.
I am.
I'm carrying your dumb ass.
I'm literally pulling both of you guys off.
Yeah, you're pulling me?
No.
I'm literally pulling you.
You're the one who fell.
Yeah, you're the one who fell.
It made us restart this entire part.
It literally wasn't me.
I'm done with this gaslighting.
When we were swinging, you fucked up.
You fucked up the swing.
Okay, Dido's gonna get hit.
Okay, no, she's not.
I'm fine.
That was scary.
Press space.
Oh my god, what the fuck is wrong with you guys?
That was...
No, I don't...
You know it.
That was...
Okay, me first.
Me first.
You gotta stay there.
She's gonna get hit.
Now!
Okay, Dido, you're last.
Come on, Dido.
Okay, me first.
Me first.
Okay.
Okay, Dido.
We did it.
Oh my god.
She did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
This one.
Okay, jump.
Pummel party.
Jump this one.
Okay.
Jump the next one.
Right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
It almost looks like all three of us missed.
This one?
Jump?
Yay!
Jump down.
Okay, okay, okay.
Calm, calm.
Calm down, guys.
We don't have to rush this one.
We don't have to rush it.
Guys.
Guys, please.
Please.
Who puts fucking lube on that shit?
You have to rush this.
Woo, woo, woo, woo, woo.
Okay, okay.
Yay.
Okay, get back.
Okay, we're back again.
We made it.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're back to 500 meters.
No counting just going.
We don't need a count.
We can read each other's minds.
We've been together for so long.
Yes.
Yeah, for sure.
It feels like five years have passed since we started chaining together.
Alright.
We don't need a sprint, guys.
Time in hell flows differently.
So it could possibly be five years.
We could have, yeah.
Honestly, this feels like it.
Alright.
Up we go.
Up we go, guys.
Slowly, slowly.
Slowly, guys.
No falling.
Don't fall.
Don't falling allowed.
We don't need a run.
We don't need a sprint for this.
Good aim.
Good aim only.
Yeah, we're FPS gamers.
We don't fall.
I can run.
Okay, no, Ditto.
You cannot.
Don't you do it.
It's maze time.
It's maze.
Oh my god.
Look at us.
We're so far.
Oh my god.
We did it again.
We're back here.
It feels like a thousand years have passed since we started this game.
We've been stuck here for a thousand years.
Up here, up here, up here.
I was testing you guys.
I knew it was up there.
No, you would not.
I wanted to make sure you guys knew it.
Okay, we gotta hug the wall.
Hug the wall so RPR doesn't throw again.
Doki, I am going.
Don't worry.
I have a clip compilation ready for you.
after stream.
My clip combination with me is going to be like 5 seconds long.
I have more clips on you than you do on me.
3, 2, 1, go.
Okay.
Okay, this is the swing part, guys.
This is the swing part.
The swing part.
I think you can go first.
Yeah, I should be the one swinging.
I should be the one swinging.
Am I staying then?
Because I am middle?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's going to go great.
I should swing.
Last time you swung, what happened?
We almost died.
No, you... last time you swung, we all died.
I will stand here.
Okay, are you guys ready?
Yeah.
Okay, try to coordinate this.
You did nothing.
Okay, that's great.
RPR.
How is this my fault?
When she jumps, she pulls me down.
RPR.
Wait.
Maybe we...
You are both dumber.
Oh, no, we can't.
No, we can't.
Listen, I will show you guys physics.
I stay here.
Stop pushing me.
Come with me.
I stay here.
And both of you jump.
You are not going to be able to keep both of us up.
You are not going to be...
Yes, I will.
Okay.
I see.
I'll carry.
I get it.
Both of you jump.
One left, one right.
Okay.
Which way?
I'll go right.
You go left.
Okay?
Ready?
Three.
Two.
One.
Jump.
Yeah.
You see?
Mathematics.
Ditto.
Yeah.
You see this?
I am the brain of operation.
Dido, we didn't.
Dido, we're so smart.
Dido...
Second jump.
Dido, we didn't.
Okay.
Second jump.
Second job.
Where do we go?
This is why I am the brain.
Where do we go, though?
This way, this way, this way.
Go third jump.
Third jump.
One.
Two.
This way, this way.
Third jump, third jump.
You know how numbers work?
They don't...
Third jump.
Number three.
One.
Okay.
Two.
Three.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I thought two.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, Ditto.
We're so smart.
Ditto.
I literally...
Someone clipped this shit, clipped this shit.
Someone clipped that shit.
We're so smart.
It was my idea.
Us and Ditto.
Ditto and I, we figured it out together.
Yeah.
Come here, come here, come here.
Oh my gosh.
This way, this...
Oh, this way.
No, your guys' idea was...
Doki's idea was, and I quote, I jump, you guys wait, and then we all fall with her.
No.
Because we didn't fall.
We didn't.
No, because we didn't fall.
I am the center of the wait.
No, we didn't fall.
The point was to swing, okay?
Somebody's coping.
Three, two, one, go.
You just don't know physics.
And that's okay.
You didn't take physics in high school, and then we're going to tell.
You didn't even graduate.
What do you mean, I didn't graduate high school?
I went to a fucking science high school, hello?
My high school was math and science.
Where's the diploma?
Where is it?
I'm not going to show you.
I'm not going to dox my fucking...
Then you didn't graduate.
You probably fucking had two in fucking...
Or what was that?
Dean.
I didn't even pass physics!
Do you even know what physics is?
I did!
I passed!
Did you?
Where's your proof?
You didn't even pass!
You didn't pass graduate high school!
The one that was shared was...
3, 2, 1, go!
Physics was my favorite subject.
Okay, this is pummel party.
Okay.
Just jump multiple times?
Who did that?
Who was it?
Now they're gonna say it was my fault.
It was you.
I went forward!
Me first, me first!
Okay, ditto.
Come on!
She's learning.
Me first!
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Okay!
We can just walk up for this.
We don't need a...
3, 2, 1, this.
We can see this and know where to do.
Okay.
Know where to do.
Guys!
Who's pulling?
Who the f...
Guys!
Jump here!
What do you mean jump here?
How are we gonna fucking...
How do we go back?
This is a skip.
There's no way.
Wait, I can't...
Just don't jump.
I can't... I can't...
I'm trying.
What do you mean you're...
Just go down.
Get over here.
I can't pull her.
Okay.
I got it.
I can't pull her.
Guys, please jump.
Jump.
I'm trying.
I can't pull her.
I can't.
You can't.
How do we...
What do you mean this is a skip?
There's...
This is a skip.
How?
I know what I'm doing.
Just come with me.
Okay.
I know the devs.
You know the devs.
Okay.
I do.
Then what do we do then?
Up here?
Yeah.
Trust me.
I know the devs.
Come.
Yeah.
Up here.
Okay.
What do we do after that?
Listen.
I know the devs.
You don't trust me.
All right.
But I do know them.
Okay.
How do we...
Jump here.
Yeah.
You see?
Didto did that?
Yeah.
I did it.
And then what?
Pull me.
Okay.
And then what?
You see this?
Yeah.
We're looking.
You see?
One second.
Yeah.
You see this?
You got to jump.
Keep jumping.
We're jumping.
I'm jumping.
Keep jumping.
I think somebody is coping.
I think we'd be at the top right now.
I feel like we'd be at the top right now.
There's an elevator here.
This way.
Maybe there's an elevator here.
I think the devs removed it.
Let's go back.
What are you doing?
Oh my God.
They removed it.
They removed it guys.
Unlucky, unlucky.
They could have been back already.
They removed it.
Trust me, trust me.
I don't think it ever existed.
RPR, I don't think...
Do you know the devs?
Yeah, I know the devs too.
I know the devs.
No you fucking don't.
No you don't.
How do you know I don't?
You don't know that.
Cause they're my friends.
They're on my friends list right now.
What's your name?
They don't know who the fuck you are.
They're on my friends list.
What's your name?
That is private information.
Oh, so you don't know.
You don't know.
What's the first letter?
No, no, no.
You say.
No, no, you say.
I have them on my friends list.
You know then you say.
I was the one that suggested the game because the devs messaged me about it.
The devs emailed me and was like you should play our game.
What's the first letter?
So what's their name?
No, cause I'm calling your club.
What's the first letter?
No, well I'm calling your club.
The first letter was B.
Bitch.
Let's move on.
The devs are gonna ban you now because you call their a bitch.
Oh my god.
I hope they ban me.
I don't wanna play this shit anymore.
Oh my god.
It's so sad.
Okay, we go again.
20 minutes have passed.
Oh my god.
Only 20.
I'm gonna let go.
20 minutes have passed.
It feels like so many hours have passed.
Please, we don't need a class.
This was your idea.
How can you...
I didn't know how dog shit I'll be at this game.
You're so bad.
You're so much worse than everyone.
What do you mean I'm so much worse?
Look at you.
Look what?
Ditto, who's the worst player?
Ditto.
I'm going.
Yeah.
What the heck?
She's flying off the map.
While she's...
Oh, man.
Oh, I saw you.
She's calling my name while she's flying off the map.
I'm going without you guys.
No, I got there first.
I would touch this laser right now.
JK.
Jump over to this one.
Are you guys kidding me?
Okay, I'm pulling.
I'm pulling.
I'm going, I'm going.
I go too, I go too.
We have to do the logs again.
We have to do the logs.
Oh my god, not this one.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Jump.
Alright, we're getting better.
We're doing this so many times.
We're getting better.
Yeah, we did this 12 times already.
Of course we'll do this.
We weren't good.
It'll be sad.
Please.
I know, I heard there's a city.
There's a city above us.
Please, I want to see the city.
We're not seeing the city.
I want to see the city.
I don't want to be in hell anymore.
Hell's nice.
It's nice and warm.
It's like summer.
I know.
I want it to be cold.
You like cold?
Yeah, because it's not human.
That's the worst part about it being warm.
It's because it's...
Oh my god, you did this to us.
You did... I watched you do it.
Why didn't you pull me up?
What do you mean?
You distracted me with conversations.
I got distracted.
You started the conversation.
Why didn't you give me a conversation?
I was thinking about the cold.
I was thinking about winter.
She starts the conversation, then she falls off, and then she blames me for starting the conversation and distracting her.
Stop!
You don't know.
Why didn't you pull me up?
I can't take this anymore.
I can't anymore.
Fall off right now.
Do it.
Come on, do it, you pussy.
Do it, you pussy.
Fall off right now.
Fall off.
Oh my god.
This is torture.
You're not even a gamer.
You beat only up, but you can't even beat chain together.
That's so sad.
You didn't even beat only up.
I did.
It's how my VODs got deleted.
No, I didn't.
I didn't.
Spies from Doki's chat.
Come in my chat and tell me if you should beat only up.
No, I didn't.
I didn't beat only up or not.
It's not my fault.
I beat it.
She didn't beat shit.
I did.
I bet that person's not even a member.
I did it in a member stream, so they missed out.
They missed out.
She did not, in fact, beat it.
Yeah.
I showed her membership right now.
It was in a member stream.
Member stream, my ass.
Member since day one, she didn't beat shit.
So it's member since day one.
Why is it calling him out?
I'll recognize the name.
What's the name?
Wait.
Did Doggy play Olios?
I don't snitch.
Yeah, I did.
And I beat it.
You beat it too, right, Ditto?
Yeah, I beat it.
Yeah.
So we all beat it.
So why can't RPR beat this game?
You did not beat only up and I don't snitch.
Then you're lying.
You could be making it up right now.
See, in my stream, I was member and I saw it.
People in my stream were like, I was member.
I've been...
Let me read this.
I've been watching Doggy POV this whole time.
Literally 90% of the polls are her fault.
That's not true.
That person, I bet...
Yeah.
Oh my God.
See,
I'm ahead of you guys.
Oh my God.
Yeah, and you're gonna get a skill as well.
It worked.
She made that message up, by the way.
You're getting exposed.
Made one message up.
Wait, what?
The one you quote unquote read from your chat?
That's not true.
I literally looked at that message.
I remember the guy's username.
It was Wario.
He exists.
He's a real person in my chat.
What's his name?
Wario.
W-I-R-Y-O.
I literally saw it.
Not real.
You're not real.
And you made me fall.
Not real plus L plus Rapalzo.
That's on you.
It's your fault that you're fucking terrible at video games other than Apex.
You're literally terrible at any game.
I'm a fucking multi-talented, multi-titled professional gamer.
In one game.
Yeah?
You're washed now.
I've competed for 17 years.
I've been competing before you knew what a PC was.
Stop rolling.
You're playing a Zelda.
You again.
It was you again.
You can't handle this anymore.
This is...
Say it.
R.P.I.
Why is this even...
Why do you keep having these conversations with me?
I can't focus.
I can't focus at all.
Now with some...
Okay, earlier you were saying, this stream can't be only you saying, go.
You have to go.
Now I'm talking, now you're falling and now it's my fault.
Yeah.
I'm glad we agree on something.
I'm glad we finally agreed on something.
That is your fault?
Yeah, yeah.
Keep falling.
That is your fault.
You're the only person here that didn't beat OnlyUp.
The only person that didn't beat OnlyUp.
I literally had someone just superchat me.
It was like, I remember when Doki beat OnlyUp.
Only took 30 minutes.
That's true.
That was his fault.
He missed the jump and made Doki fall.
That is so true.
I did not miss the jump.
I grabbed the ledge.
She made that superchat up, by the way.
That is not true.
Drez is a real person in my chat.
Yeah, I can also just pick one name out of my chat and pretend they gave me $100.
Dude, Zikir, thank you so much for the $100 bomb.
I've been watching Doki stream this entire time and she's lying.
So I know.
It would be more believable if you talked about like, bitties.
Because it's a Twitch stream.
BDJ.
Thank you for 10 gifted Ditos.
It's Dito's fault.
See, like...
Why are you blaming Ditto?
Ditto is doing the best she can.
It's not me.
It's the chatter.
That is so fucked up, RPR.
I didn't fall.
Yeah.
Ditto didn't do anything.
You're blaming on her.
Guys, it's not me.
It's the chatter.
That is so messed up.
I'm just reading chat.
I'm just giving like you RPR.
You're the baby.
Farno, thank you for $10.
Yes, I agree.
Doki is always fucking...
That's so messed up that you're blaming Ditto.
She did nothing wrong.
Yeah.
Ditto is actually the one heart-carrying all of us right now.
Your chat is toxic.
The Ditto that got hit by the windmill 14 times in a row...
14 times.
It's actually 15 times.
Look at...
Look, I made it.
I made it though.
It's a speedrun, Tek.
Ditto is...
Ditto is heart-carrying both of us right now, RPR.
Why are you blaming her?
She's actually heart-carrying us.
I even carried the swing.
We came up with the idea.
You could have done the swing without us.
You could have done the swing without Ditto and I.
Yeah, you can't...
Yeah, we coordinated the right and the left.
If you came up with the idea, then how...
Chat.
What is the reason?
Chad told us how to do it.
No, no, no, but what is the reason that strat worked?
It's because Ditto and I swung... jumped the right way.
That is the dumbest shit I've ever heard in my life.
I swear to fucking god.
Okay, guys.
Don't pull.
Guys, guys, guys.
Why did you guys pull me?
Oh my god.
How is this how?
This is...
It's my favorite part again.
Okay, Doki.
Doki, once and for all, I'm gonna explain the swing strat to you.
The reason the swing strat works is because I am the middle and I am the center of the gravity.
So if you two jump on each side, I will not fly off.
Because equal weight will be distributed on both sides.
Do you understand this?
No, got it.
No, I understand.
I'm not stupid.
Why are you talking to Ditto and I?
I said, what?
We're like children.
I'm not talking to Ditto and you.
Why are you treating us like kids?
I'm only talking to you like you're children.
Get it right.
It's called a pulley system, RnPr.
You don't even know the right name for it.
Doki, Doki.
It's literally the pulley system.
The last four drops have been your fault.
That's not true.
That is not true.
This is a team effort.
We're chained together.
You just didn't like IGLS better.
You should have done it three times in a row.
What are you doing?
What do you mean?
I'm like ahead of you guys.
What are you doing?
What do you mean?
I'm literally ahead of you guys.
Like, what are you talking about?
I literally made it.
Chill out, bro.
Yeah, no.
We are so...
All of us in here are so mad.
I'm so upset.
Guys, why you guys do this to me?
You agreed to play this game.
What?
It still works.
Ditto, Ditto.
I got pumped.
My dad owns YouTube and told me Doki's viewership is actually just one guy on 5000 PCs.
Yeah.
He's carrying this game right now.
He's giving us all the right information.
But his dad owns YouTube.
He's really exposed.
Yeah.
For months now, I have fabricated your viewership by creating thousands and thousands of accounts.
And now to prove this point, I will copy paste this message with all of my accounts.
Okay.
If he really wants to do that successfully, it has to be a short-term.
Don't fall.
Don't fall, RPR.
RPR, don't fall.
Don't fall.
Don't fall, RPR.
We saw that.
Yeah, but you see, when I fall, I save it.
You just fall.
No, I saved it, but then you pushed me.
Okay.
You saved yourself.
You can push this game.
Yes, you can.
At a certain point of the map, we didn't have the push mechanic.
I know the devs and you don't.
And I know this for life.
I knew the devs.
You called the devs a bitch.
So, like, you don't have the...
No, I don't.
I don't have the permission anymore.
But you wouldn't know that because you're not tight like that with devs like I am.
Oh, yeah?
What's their name?
I don't know their nickname because we're tight like that with homies.
Oh, yeah.
You don't know their names because you're tight like that.
Then they're not homies.
Then what's their nickname?
Their nickname is bitch?
Listen, Doki.
There's guys I know on the internet whose IRL name I do not know and I've known them for 17 years.
Okay?
Then you're not this homie's homie.
You think they're your homie, but you're not their homie.
I've met this person like seven times IRL.
Yeah, but you're not close enough.
You're like an acquaintance then.
Okay, but give me one good reason why I would need to know their name.
Because you're like, hey, I need you...
What?
You're like, hey, I need you.
I need you.
Can I see how you do your tax forms, homie?
I need help with taxes.
Can I see an example of how you do your taxes?
Doki, let me explain something.
In Europe, right?
Yeah.
There's about a 400 million countries and all tax firms are different.
Even if I knew his name, what the fuck can he do to me to help me with my taxes when he lives in a different country?
He can help you with calculations.
What do you mean?
I can count.
I went to a math school.
You went to a math school?
Masqal?
Math and science.
Why do you like this then?
Why do you like this?
I'm li- 3, 2, 1, go.
I literally fixed our- our- our swinging issue using physics.
And you call me dumb.
Can I remind you what your idea was again?
A swing.
It was- you- you built off my initial hypothesis.
Yeah, your idea is I jump guys and then it's gonna happen.
Okay.
Fuck man, I think I got copypasted.
I go left.
I go right.
You ready?
3, 2, 1, go.
Alright, just go forward.
Go forward.
Okay, Okay.
Dang.
Nice, nice.
We did it Ditto.
Yes.
Nice.
1 second.
Okay 1...
2...
If it's one, 1.
Oh my god the math student knows how to count to 2.
1...
2.
2...
Wow.
We did it guys lolol.
Nice.
Oh my god everyone is spamming the copypaster now.
I've got the room that can't even read it anymore.
Ahahaha.
Easier to read?
You come to mine or Ditto's chat to have a good chatting experience.
You sent in your spies to destroy my chat.
Ready?
Go.
We did it, guys.
Where did we die?
I don't know.
Go.
I think it was here, wasn't it?
Yeah, it's right here.
You see the lasers?
3, 2, 1, go.
I see the lasers, guys.
Okay.
Slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Slowly.
Right here.
Wait, did we die at the lasers?
Yeah, we died at the lasers.
Yeah.
3, 2, 1, go.
Guys, I'm scared.
Let's come up with a strategy.
3, 2, 1, go.
Okay, strategy.
We go... We run until... You stupid.
We run until the middle and then we jump.
You know what?
Let's just wing it.
Fuck it.
3, 2, 1, go.
Jump.
Go.
We did it.
Jump.
Holy shit, I'm so smart.
You said you are not smart.
You literally said...
Guys, guys, guys.
Why didn't you say jump?
Because we don't need that anymore.
3, 2, 1, go.
But you fall.
They don't literally clutch it for us.
They don't literally clutch that.
Guys, I just did everything and I still got zero credit.
Ditto clutched that for us.
Your plan was like, let's wing it.
That is your plan.
Some fucking math and science dude that said just wing it.
I just did everything and I got zero credit.
Yeah, just like...
What?
You did everything.
What do you mean you did everything?
Ditto clutched it.
We made it to the subway because of Ditto.
At least credit Ditto for her hard work.
You can't say wing it and claim credit for everything.
But I was the one that said how we're gonna wing it.
Ready to jump here?
Yeah.
3, 2, 1, go.
We did it.
We come, we come, Shay.
Yeah, just slow and steady guys.
Slow and steady.
This is just jumps.
Oh yeah, we're not gonna die here.
Go.
Guys, guys.
Ditto, Ditto, Ditto.
Ditto, what are you doing, Ditto?
Okay, 3, 2, 1, go.
Guys, Ditto.
Hey, Ditto.
Ditto, Ditto, Ditto.
Please, Ditto, Ditto.
Okay, I will admit that was the first mistake I've made today.
That was the first mistake I've ever made today.
I am willing to take the blame for the first mistake.
She said that was the first.
It's down there.
I see it.
Guys, I'm gonna be real with you guys.
We're not doing all that again.
I'm not doing all that again.
It's all the way down there.
Okay, this way.
I see the right.
Yeah, you see it?
Yeah, I see it.
It's right here.
Jump!
Ready?
Yeah.
To the right.
To the front of us.
Three, two, one, go.
Here, okay.
And jump again.
Jump to the cross.
Jump to the cross here.
To the cross, dude.
Three, two, one, go.
There we go.
See?
We're doing it, guys.
Okay.
See, at least I am an adult and I can admit when I fuck up.
Okay, every single time you've fallen, you've said, somehow we pushed you or pulled you or made you distracted.
I know.
So every time you've fallen, it was our fault, even though you fell.
No, no, no.
It wasn't everybody's fault.
It was your fault.
Uh-huh.
Ditto was innocent.
I don't know why you keep dragging Ditto into this argument.
Yeah, I know.
She has not done anything wrong.
Yeah.
Yep.
That makes everything so much better.
Yeah.
We're doing it, guys.
Teamwork.
Yeah, we're doing it.
I remember these.
Teamwork, guys.
Next fall, I'm going to bed.
I'm not even kidding.
It's 4 a.m.
Guys, please.
Guys, guys, guys.
Teamwork.
Teamwork, guys.
All right.
I'm going to hug the wall.
Teamwork, guys.
Next fall is bed, okay?
Next fall is bed.
It's 4 a.m.
Okay.
But what if you're the one...
It's 9 a.m.
All right.
Whoever falls is the reason why we're losing.
No.
Yep.
All right.
Whoever falls is the reason.
Three, two, one, go.
All right.
Are we going to beat this game?
You're in the most dangerous.
You know that?
Are we ever going to beat this game, guys?
No.
I'm going to install it after this.
Guys, we're going to hit 600, guys.
Do you think we can hit 1,000?
Okay.
I want to see the city.
Ready, Ditto?
Three, two, one, go.
I invented this shot, though.
Oh, yeah.
You invented the pulley system.
Yep.
I invented that.
Well, one.
One.
Two.
Okay.
There you go.
One.
Two.
Okay.
We did it.
We're doing it, guys.
Okay.
I'm a little worried that we're not calling the jumps for this.
Why?
It's small.
Every jump matters now.
All right.
What the fuck?
How did I get pulled up there?
These are easy jumps.
Easy jumps.
Okay.
Three, two, one, go.
Easy jump.
Walking, walking, running, running, running.
All right.
Easy jump.
Easy jumps.
RPR.
I thought it was easy.
RPR?
I thought this was easy.
You guys pulled me.
How did we pull you?
Three, two, one, go.
No complaining.
Just jumping.
Okay.
Three, two, one, go.
We wing it.
Now.
Jump.
All right.
Three.
No.
You watch my legs go up.
Three, two, one, go.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Yes.
Okay, we got it.
Okay.
2, 1, go.
Yay!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, this is where we fall.
This is where we fell.
Okay, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Jump over laser.
Okay, now we count here, okay?
3, 2, 1, go.
Okay, we're dead.
I'm dead.
No, no, no.
Pull me faster.
Pull me, pull me, pull me.
I'm pulling, I'm pulling, I'm pulling.
She's not pulling.
You both have to pull.
Don't fall, Dito.
Do not fall.
Dito, do not fall.
I'm pressing.
I got you.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, we win.
How the fuck are we going to do this?
I saved you guys.
Remember what I did?
How are we going to win?
No, you always said wing it.
Fuck it.
Just follow me, okay?
We go...
We go... now.
Now go.
Jump.
Jump again.
Just out the porch.
I'm dead.
We didn't follow you down.
We can do this again.
No, I'm not.
I'm fucking done.
No, no more.
No more.
That wasn't me.
I know for sure that wasn't me.
Who was it?
Who the fuck was it?
Who touched it?
RPR, did you touch it?
That one was hard as fuck.
How did you beat that one?
How do you not touch the laser?
By the way, it was all of us.
All of us got it.
I was on the other side.
Oh my god.
Not my fault.
I made...
I admit my mistakes.
You didn't admit your mistakes.
Ditto and I both admit it when we fucked up.
I said it was all of our fault there.
I screwed it.
I'm sorry that I'm a perfect human being and I just don't make mistakes.
I'm sorry.
She did.
We all made goodbyes.
I don't make mistakes.
My bad.
Let's look at everything that we did today guys.
Look at the beautiful scenery.
Look at the beautiful...
This is everything we did.
We actually went up quite a lot.
It's so beautiful.
Jump off the map.
Can we?
No, we can't.
What the fuck?
This way.
It's so beautiful.
That's us right there.
I wish that was me right now.
I wish that was me.
Those people are too big.
Oh my god.
You're right.
How big are these people?
I'm glad.
Are we gonna beat this?
Are we ever gonna beat this guys?
Are we gonna beat this game?
Guys...
Yo, you wanna go for round two?
Are we gonna beat it?
You wanna go for round two on this?
Yeah, I'm down.
Just the fucking way you're down.
You're a quitter.
You're a coward.
They don't know I can... are down for it.
You're a quitter.
Let's do it then.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's beat this game.
Not now.
Next time.
I'm not gonna stream it guys.
I'm not gonna.
What do you mean you're not gonna stream it?
When do we beat this off stream?
Yeah, we'll beat it off stream.
I'll just give the controller to my brother.
Yeah, yeah.
Same vibe.
Let me DM the speedrunner for the speedrunner team.
Oh my god.
Okay, so you know how this game is on Steam?
So like we hire a speedrunning team.
And then we ask them to change their names to our name.
And then like record it.
And then we voice act it.
That's more effort than actually beating the game.
No it's not.
Cause for them it only takes two hours.
It only takes two hours to beat the game.
But you have to voice act two hours of the...
Yeah, but we can just stream it.
We stream them playing.
One of them stream...
Like each of them screen share.
And then we voice act it.
You just called me a quitter.
And this is your shot at beating the game.
They'll never know.
They just have to copy our names.
You see this would have worked.
If you didn't say the entire time.
I would lie.
Yeah, but like...
But then what if that's just a bait?
That's just a bait.
So now they'll never know.
Like if we're actually playing it or not.
Yeah.
Maybe we didn't play this entire time.
Yeah, maybe we didn't play this entire time.
Maybe we already hired the speedrunners chat.
Yeah, and they were falling for two hours.
Yeah, because they want to make it believable.
Yeah, that's why they didn't even get to...
We didn't even get to half of the map.
Because they want to make it believable.
Because they think we're that fucking dumb.
Yeah, our voice acting.
We were just showing off our voice acting.
They're saying we're going to need a hand cam next time.
We did it guys!
Guys, we beat the game.
That's why we're in the beginning.
If we're watching now, we beat the game.
And that's why we're at the beginning of the map.
One hour, 59 minutes and 27 seconds.
New world record by the way.
Yippee!
Round of applause for me.
Yay!
For Ditto and I.
For me, for Cary.
Yay!
For Ditto and I.
Next time we're going to do it blindfolded.
All for us.
This did not feel like 2 hours.
This was the longest 2 hours.
This was the longest 2 hours of our lives.
I felt like...
I felt like I had to play this game for like 8 hours.
Oh my God.
Ditto, how long have you been live, Ditto?
How long have you been live, Ditto?
15 hours.
Oh my god.
Go to bed.
I'm gonna go to bed.
I was playing Powerball.
The reason we stopped playing is because Dita has to go to bed.
Otherwise we would beat the game.
We would beat the game if she didn't have to go to bed.
But she has to go to bed so we can't beat the game.
Yeah, exactly guys.
We had to stop because Dita has to sleep now guys.
That is why.
We didn't give up.
We were very considerate over Dita's sleep schedule.
She's been out for like 15 hours now.
Because of that, we're stopping because we care about Dita.
Someone said keep playing as a duo then.
We can't play without Dita.
Yeah, we can't play without Dita.
Dita is a team.
I don't want to watch you guys play Dita.
We're a trio.
It's like Apex Legends.
We're slightly Minhera.
Team slightly Minhera.
We can't be like Minhera without Dita.
Team severely Minhera.
Without Dita we'll just be like not Minhera.
You guys more like Minhera than me.
You're the one that streamed 15 hours.
That's Minhera behavior.
Why do you stream so much?
I'm addicted to Powerwell.
That's why you're in Minhera.
You're addicted to Powerwell.
I'm wasting precious minutes I could be sleeping.
Precious minutes are being wasted.
Look at me press Alt F4.
We're looking.
I'm gone.
I'm not there.
I'm going.
GG guys.
I had a great time.
I can't wait.
I can't wait for our next one.
I can't wait till we beat this.
We're going to beat it.
We're going to see the city.
Next time we should bring Uto.
When we're struggling as three.
As four we're not going to get past the car.
Uto is going to get mad.
Think about it.
He's going to get mad.
With four people there's one more person to carry.
Think about it.
How are you going to do the pulley system with four?
Two people stay in the middle.
And two swing.
It works the same way.
No.
That doesn't work because there's more weight on the center.
Two go left and two go right.
That's easy.
What do you mean two go left?
And you went to science school?
You're not going to fall.
If there's two people in the center then the weight distribution will pull to the right.
It's balanced.
You went to the science school?
That's not physics.
Oh my gosh.
I'm here.
Thank you guys for watching.
This was a great time.
I'll see you guys for the next chain record.
I'm going to talk to my dragoons.
Bye.
Good night.
I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
Alright.
I'm going to figure out why my my my GoXLive for some reason was not was like so quiet today.
Okay.
I'm going to I'm going to Oh my gosh.
What the fuck is that sound?
What the fuck?
Sorry.
I had an ad.
I was like Oh my god.
I was like My phone played the ad.
Okay.
I'm going to call it here.
GG's.
I'll be at AvCon tomorrow.
Well tomorrow for me.
I don't know dates right now.
I'm a mess at the moment.
But I had a great time.
Oh yes.
I had a great time as always.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
If you didn't sit up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.